well it's almost time for kids to head
back to school and nevada partners has
teamed up with several organizations to
bring supplies to families in need
they're holding a fair today it's
happening until 8 o'clock tonight near
lake mead and revere
allegiant stadium the las vegas raiders
starbucks and early learning academy are
all helping get backpacks and supplies
to children all across clark county
ashanti lewis with nevada partners
explains how this back to school fair is
also helping kids with personal care we
give away hygiene kids
we have a lot of need in the community
so when we have events like this we try
to reach
everybody and give away as many
resources as we can this
area of town is is continuously growing
we have a lot of people here
we are impacted by poverty we always
have been we're looking to change that
it is first come first serve as the line
started forming around
4 this afternoon it's pretty crowded
there again the fair lasts
until 8 o'clock nevada partners no idea
is required